Super Mario maker - Cana seems like a
game you can play forever and Kevin you
and I got to play for about 90 minutes
yep and I definitely agree with you even
in that fairly brief time I think we
only scratched the surface of all the
options and just the sheer amount of
things you could do with that
yeah I've sort of been thinking of the
first Super Mario maker as like the
introduction to the book and then Super
Mario maker 2 is the book of everything
you can actually do and there was
already so much to do in the first game
but that the second game is just
completely blown it out of the water
starting with the fact that the second
game actually has a story mode this time
it does it's not quite like a
traditional story mode that you find in
a Mario platformer like you're not going
from one world to another or on your way
to rescue Princess Peach it seems more
like a structured way to guide you
through all the different like pre-made
courses that are in the game yeah it
seems like a good way maybe if you are
not so sure about building levels
yourself it seems like a good way to
sort of get introduced to all the new
mechanics like the first couple levels
we play they show you the new Angry Sun
they show you the red blue switches so
if there's maybe some Mario elements
you're unfamiliar with you can jump in a
story mode and learn how they work
mm-hmm it definitely seems like there's
a lot of freedom to how you approach the
story mode - because the ultimate goal
of it is to gather up enough funds to
rebuild Princess Peach's castle but you
could decide like which part of the
castle you want to build first and to
get coins you'll need to take on jobs
from our new favorite character task
master toad yeah I don't know how I feel
about the name task master toad but
that's what they call him
but yeah each each of the jobs amounts
to a traditional side-scrolling Mario
level and some of them have certain
clear conditions that you need to meet
yeah that's one of the new things they
introduced is now these levels have
clear conditions as opposed to just
getting to the flagpole when we were
playing around in build mode for example
I could set a condition to be like you
have to defeat this magic koopa in order
to finish the level
uh-huh that already makes my mind spin
with possibilities about the levels you
could build right because you could have
something that's like go to the four
corners of this map collect these four
items and then you can clear the level
almost like a 2d Super Mario 64 course
uh-huh you could also make a level where
you aren't supposed to jump at all you
can make yourself unable to jump or you
can even set a clear condition that's
like once you jump you can't touch the
ground
and so let's just talk about that let's
talk about the course building because
it really is the meat of the game and
like we're saying the amount of things
you can build in this game is absolutely
insane yep of course the first thing I
had to do was build just like some sort
of nightmarish punishing level because
that's all I want to make with this with
the first game my brother and I would
like build courses and just challenge
each other with them and now we can
actually make them together because
they're new there's that new co-op
feature when you're building levels we
didn't get a chance to try that oh but
I'll be honest I I'm a little bit iffy
now on doing co-op building now having
played Mario maker to using the pro
controller to build obviously when
you're doing platforming the pro
controller feels fine but when you're
building a course you really want to use
the touchscreen absolutely yeah the pro
controller controls just did not feel
good I did not think they were very
intuitive I definitely ended up like
dragging things farther than I wanted or
even just navigating the menu was a
little weird so you're gonna build
definitely recommend using the
touchscreen controls I definitely
recommend looking into a stylus for your
switch - yeah for sure
but that said there are some quality of
life improvements as far as how you
could build courses now well in the
original game you'd say have to shake
certain items or enemies in order to
change their state and while I was very
charming I can imagine that it wouldn't
work very well at all with the pro
controller so now instead of having to
do that you could just tap out an enemy
and then there's all these different
options that you could choose from yeah
it's like a tap and a hold if you want
to adjust that stuff one of the things
you can adjust that's really cool is if
you drop in the angry son who I'm sure
will mention a couple times in this
preview you tap him you can turn him
into a moon when you do that you unlock
the night variations of all the courses
which are then they those add even more
possibilities of the jungle level
becomes like the one that mushroom
becomes the poison mushroom yeah ninety
minutes was not nearly enough do
everything I wanted to do with that game
no not at all but it was enough to build
an evil course if you're interested in
checking out that level we built you can
certainly check out that gameplay on
GameSpot we've got that whole course
building and course completion up
[Music]
speaking of beating courses though we
should talk about the online component
of this game definitely so like the
original Super Mario maker you're able
to jump online you could share your own
courses or you could play other people's
courses this time around you could like
search for courses using tags so that
makes it a bit easier to find like the
certain type of course you want like say
you want to find one to focus all on
speedrunning or with it that's set and
like what a specific theme it's much
easier to filter out the courses you
want to play this time one of the new
features with the online mode - that I
really like is the endless mode I
believe they call it where it's
literally pick a difficulty level and
we're gonna feed you as many games as
you can handle as many courses as you
can handle
until you lose so like I said before
this is a game that you can kind of play
forever
that's a mode that's immediately built
for it right out of the gate I can only
imagine how much of a nightmare that's
going to be once the game is live yeah
cuz even in what we played there was
some really difficult tricky courses in
there the one thing I really enjoyed too
is any course you can take on
cooperatively doesn't matter if it was
built intentionally for it or not you
can go back and play it with up to four
players yep just that completely changes
the way you're going to play the level
and not just because you can of course
bounce off each other's heads and then
and that sort of thing but yeah it
completely changes the way you play
level you can work together to take out
enemies or one of you can I don't know
if you could really distract Bowser but
one of you can hit you know focus on
maybe getting around him while another
can Pelt him with fireballs like it
completely opens up new ways to play the
level you already beat it feels a lot
like the multiplayer and the New Super
Mario Bros games yes because they're all
sharing the same screen you could all in
vertically get in each other's way and
if somebody dies they come back they
float back in a bubble and you're right
pop them to bring them back into the
game and of course you can also build
courses that need to be beaten by
multiple people right there's certain
tricks you can do as far as whether it's
bouncing off each other's heads or
carrying multiple items whatever it is
you can build a course that demands four
people in order to actual
finish it and that's another area where
having clear conditions completely
changes the whole game
because we played one level where we
needed to collect all 99 coins in order
before we could be able to finish it
we all had to be cat Mario to climb on
the fences and so yeah it was just an
absolute scramble to like grab the bells
avoid being eaten by like the big big
purple cheep cheeps or whatever they are
and then collect them all and it was
completely crazy I think I grabbed the
last coin and I just like sprinted to
the end even bother to pop anybody else
I was just like we're done here while we
didn't try any of them ourselves you can
also build a level that's designed
competitively yes you can have levels
that say okay get to the end but have
the most coins or just be the first to
the end but and so that's just another
option again for playing these courses
you can play by yourself you can play
with friends you can play them against
friends you can build all your own the
amount of content here is insane and
yeah it honestly it seems like something
you can kind of just play for a fee
basically just get an endless supply of
courses and play them you know in
different variations and it's still very
impressive to me just how easy it is to
like learn and actually use all the
tools at your disposal
yeah the first game taught me a lot
about Mario that I didn't know you could
do before huh and I'm really excited to
learn new things like that with the
sequel and to try out those new tricks
and to build these courses because the
stuff we saw was just so inspirational
you're so creative I cannot wait to make
more of it myself absolutely me too well
we'll get to do that on June 28th and
the game heads to Nintendo's switch it's
coming in two different versions one is
the $60 version another is $70 the $70
one comes with a year of Nintendo switch
online normally that cost 20 bucks so
you're saving 10 bucks there and if
you're already a member it stacks on to
your current membership which is pretty
nice so stay tuned any game spot for
more Super Mario maker 2 coverage I know
I definitely can't wait until it finally
comes out
[Music]